I'll block you with my ball my big black
whoa okay 1,000% impossible okay I
didn't even start yes it's all calm down
for okay live bargain liar obstacle wow
that was some obstacle whoa I'm gonna
try you just once very hard not
impossible hi Margaret look oh god
[Music]
thanks for coming in late death Oh Oh
take my son am i oh I went a wrong way
what are you doing son what are you son
son son son oh my god son you almost
maybe die huh that looks like a pit of
death oh no no
again without getting every single way -
oh god now go
we're telling me is that oh wait for the
video it is short so don't worry okay
video
[Music]
Oh
okay all right that's awesome
oh thank you this is another level by
Caspi if you couldn't tell Casspi style
that was that bestest warms my heart
kind of offsets all the silliness and
depth that fills most of these episodes
but thank you so much
markiplier cincy Oh fellow Cincinnati er
well then you obviously were correct in
making a masturbate a whole time skyline
yes please
I'm going back there oh I'm going back
to Cincinnati tomorrow to spend
Thanksgiving with my family so I
is there even a win here there's no win
here is it I was looking around for the
win didn't tell me wait a minute here
don't be like that the sassy sue don't
drive here or here why give up well
found the key in the late oak wasn't
that died out about ten years ago or
something okay
well like I said I'm only continuing
because I'm obligated to save time
except whoa okay so I gotta what okay so
why did I go through such rigorous speed
miss okay now get stupid this time don't
get stupid don't be stupid for
nothing can stop me now oh wow if you
really wanted to make this impossible
you've really done a good job it's more
impossible okay what why why do you have
to tell me I failed I know
okay okay okay we're still here tell him
I said don't move hi moved our blog quiz
huh
what's Marc's full name market where
fish pucker mark Joshua's an girl I
would love that name that's an awesome
name
try Alan oh no not death Mark Edward a
fish about okay buddy up in the cage
shop in what rage game this market em
not to swear God I don't even know who's
it unfair platformer that's so long ago
no not cat Mari Raleigh cat Mario I
don't know okay and prop hunt
shenanigans what a mark and Bob gets
stuck together as a fish in a traffic
cone there was so much fan art of that
look it up I'm not weird I know myself
whoa whoa whoa okay I gotta make sure I
do this correctly widen the world okay
forward
[Music]
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye